can't peel manis van Davion and mike gam
man we really love you y'all stupid
body dirt is wanna give a couple of
notes yeah one seen in this particular
show man it was it was like dude
[Music]
the first thing like when the lights
came up we should have seen is a dick on
his chest and then y'all should just put
dicks all over the place man nothing to
put a dick put a bigger mulch and dig on
your face put a dig on start with the
punchline
that's right yeah nothing would be good
man is if his mama had come in there
[Music]
college is no he'd be like shut up bitch
have you had like a third roommate man
the muffler's outside like with a cup up
on a door like this maybe like I'm at
surface like I'm gonna go yeah there you
go mop will be going to talk about time
out what's what what and the tubes in a
minute oh man you bet crazy man dick on
my chest I'll do me like that man
- good - does it come by tell me what's
going on
Darnell I got me like Shh be quiet
listen this is he let them listen new
job oh man now you got dicks all over me
to go
that's my didn't put some balls on
his ass right now oh I mean it was
almost damn like dead dog it was like
damn man you are almost there
we laugh hog we saw that dick don't know
she was honey
you